Jenna Johnson reveals she's been hit
with tragedy the death of her baby niece
the daughter of Jenna's brother Skyler
and sister-in-law Ashton Lennon Skye
Johnson died last week the couple
revealed the heartbreaking news on
social media quote our sweet little
angel girl was stillborn Jenna says
she's quote in all of their examples of
Hope in a measurable strength during
this heart-wrenching time amid their
grief Jenna's grateful for her forever
family who came together to honor their
quote beautiful niece
Jen is enduring this tragedy while
pregnant with her and husband Val
chamirkovsky's first child a baby boy
I'm
sending more it's been very
month I would say I've been starting to
pop more and more and I'm like the
anxiety of just having to hide it you
know so I'm so happy it's on display
it's out there yes and
beyond that I'm just so excited to
finally become parents and to have our
own little little one running around
Jenna ends her tribute on Instagram by
asking fans to send Skyler and Ashton
quote all the love and prayers
thank you
[Music]